well let's head back now to the unrest
in Iraq the country's stepping up its
response to mass protests across the
country that protest includes an attack
on an Iranian embassy last week a trove
of secret reports and cables from Iran's
spy agency were published by the
intercept and the New York Times
shedding light on Tehran's vast
influence in Iraq according to the
documents Iran used the US withdrawal in
2011 to expand its influence and
surveillance operations adding top Iraqi
government politicians military and
security officials to their payroll both
in Baghdad and the semi-autonomous
Kurdish region of northern Iraq they
have routinely reported back to Tehran
about conversations with American
diplomats the documents also show how
Iran has protected and paid former CIA
informants in Iraq you've kept tabs on
US activists there well let's speak now
with Ma jobs weary he's director of the
Gulf Study Center at Cairo University
and joins us live from Doha good to have
you with us on the program and let's
turn to the protests first of all and
the the escalation and the violence and
why do you think an Iranian embassy was
attacked when the protesters are clear
in their demands about was like a change
in government's in Iraq itself in the
past few weeks there is no doubt that
there was a process of rebirth in Iraq
and that a process basically talking
about the new national identity chorus
you know sects cross ethnicities across
tribes all of these things so what
happened now in Iraq is an evidence that
people they are fed up of the you know
outsider and interventions and I think
we also see that how much this the
outsider and outside intervention has
corrupted the political atmosphere more
and more and it creates a political
elite which is more corrupted more
related its interest to the outsiders
rather than to the interest of the
people and this kind of level of anger
increasing increased rapidly in the last
few years with the
with the expansion of you know
corruption and poverty and the need and
the lack of infrastructure and the
services which the government
unfortunately have failed to deliver to
its own people but in terms of an
Iranian embassy being attacked who are
the protesters more angry at are they
angry at their government or are they
angry at Iran I think both because
simply it's very interesting to see this
happens to the Iraqi consulate Iranians
usually they used to they have this is
this is tradition to attack embassies
and consulates we witness that in the
last forty years now this time
Iranian concerts been targeted I think
what's interesting those demonstrators
they are against both they are against
the Iraqi government because there's the
assumption that this government is very
weak is actually rely on outsiders and
more important they are upset of the
Iraq of the Iranian intervention allure
enter all business in Iraq and they see
that this kind of intervention is not
helping Iraqis is actually create or
contribute to see Iraq as a failed state
and that basically bring more anger to
do them the Iraqi society and if we turn
to these these leaked cables for just a
moment I mean there are some startling
revelations in there and it does it does
imply that there is Iran is playing a
big hand in the running of Iran it gives
this we turn out to be the case I mean
how do you see the the Iraqi governments
quieting down the protesters how do you
see them making efforts to tamp down
these protests because those revelations
are likely to anger people more rather
than less surely in April 2003 I wrote
an article I said in that article that
there is a political security vacuum in
Iraq and the only regional power can can
fill it is Iran and that that's kind of
production approved to be right simply
because the United States was not was
not showing interest to a lot of
elements in Iraq they are interested
just to see Saddam Hussein disappeared
and they wanted to control oil but they
have no interest to look at other
socio-political asma to the Iraq
Iran actually worked quickly to fill
that vacuum and the sense that 2003 they
worked hardly to and to intervene in
different elements within Iraqi society
they they work with Sunnis Russia I
would college with different to group
would with the Christians because they
wanted to dominate they want to control
the political scene in a very short
sentence they want Iraq to be weak but
also they want to see an a stated Iraq
but weak and can be managed and that
what happened basically even they have
no interest to see a strong you know
religious circle in Iraq even that was
basically helped them to maintain calm
and measured as the center for Shia
clinic in the world so basically it was
obvious that you know Iranian had a
clear plan how to things should be done
in Iraq and I think the role of the
United State let's not forget 2005 the
United State Bush took to to have a
negotiation about security of Iraq with
the United State with the absent of the
Iraqi government so basically even there
are the Americans promoted the role of
Iran because they wanted that role and
they their assumption was if Iranian
intervene maybe al-qaeda will be less
you know influential so that there were
a lot of miscalculations Americans was
was actually playing a big role in this
Mahmoud is very good to have your
thoughts on the program thank you very
much indeed for joining us my from the
user